so we've discussed a lot of serious
topics on the show this week and here we
are at the last segment on a Friday and
this would be a good time to lighten the
mood and talk about something a bit more
fun and humorous but unfortunately we
can't do that today uh not after our
intern Holly informed me of a recent
trend on Tik Tok and it may be the worst
one of all it's a trend called girl math
there are a bunch of videos explaining
this concept uh here's one that I think
lays it out pretty clearly watch so for
example if you spend $100 and you get a
$10 reward you just made
$10 that's that's that's that's not
accurate that's that's not how that
works yeah because now in a future
purchase you just saved yourself
$10 if you return an item at the store
you just earn money so if you return
something and buy something at the same
time it was free no no no you cuz you
had to spend the money the first time no
but then the second time it's free cuz
it's no extra money or like if you pay
for cash with something it's free
because it's not coming out of your bank
account oh my God I I just I I feel like
or this one's so good like if you go to
Starbucks or Duncan and you use your app
you scan and pay it's free I'm never
because that money was already there I'm
never going to have money never what do
you mean it's this just this is this is
your mindset when you go to a store
honestly is this how you this is just
how girl math works girl math isn't a
thing right so that's girl math and as
you can see as you already expected girl
math is just bad math it's not math it's
anti-th and now in this age of
egalitarianism it won't surprise you to
learn that apparently there's also a boy
maath Trend but we don't need to watch
any of those videos we already know what
boy math is boy math is also known as
math it's just regular math rooted in
the basic principles of arithmetic and
other fundamental mathematical Concepts
whereas girl math is rooted in wishes
and dreams and magic fairy dust and I'm
very familiar with girl math myself my
wife uses this form of calculation all
the time and I can't tell you how many
times I've had a conversation quite
similar to what you just heard In that
clip uh very often I'll come home from
work and there will be a new piece of
Decor in the living room that my wife
decided we desperately needed and of
course I won't notice the item she could
remodel the entire living room and I
would not notice this is one of the
great many stereotypes that is nearly
100% accurate as a man I will fail to
notice major physical changes made
inside the house but I will notice
somebody changes the setting on the
thermostat by one degree in either
direction and and these are cliches for
a reason anyway invariably my wife will
call attention to the new item and
she'll say something like didn't you
notice the new lamp I guess I got a new
lamp it really ties the room together
now I thought the room was already tied
together it certainly didn't seem in any
way untied before this so I'll look at
the lamp and I will say tell me how much
you spent on it and then I'll tell you
how great it is because the lamp's
beauty entirely depends on how expensive
it was was there's an inverse
relationship between how expensive it is
and how and how beautiful I think it is
tell me the lamp was $3 at a garage sale
and I will admire it as the most
beautiful lamp ever crafted by human
hands that'll be my response or words to
that effect but then my wife will tell
me that the lamp was not $3 it was like
$85 and I'll inform her that that I
could have bought her five lamps at
Wallmart for that price okay on that
budget I could get a lamp for every room
in the house you want lamps I'll get
lamps I'll get you all the lamps you
want for less than that I have nothing
against lamps but why do you need to
spend $85 on one that's when the girl
math kicks in and she'll inform me that
the lamp was originally $185 so she
saved $100 in fact she'll tell me she
actually made us $100 she came away with
100 in profit by finding this sweet deal
on this lamp which which would kind of
Be True in a certain
way if somebody had put a gun to her
head and demanded that you buy a lamp
worth $185 in that
scenario it and you're forced to buy a
lamp and you found a lamp marked down
from 185 to 85 then we might be able to
say in essence that you saved $100 but
fortunately there's no lamp obsessed
gunman forcing us to make a lamp
purchase so the other option instead of
the $85 lamp was no lamp at all which
means that we didn't save $100 we lost
85 the fact that in some theoretical
universe lamp would have cost more than
it does doesn't help us like it doesn't
put money back in our bank account
besides I'm not convinced that we need
any lamps at all in the first place
nobody had lamps for thousands of years
and they survived they may seem extreme
but I believe in being Frugal unless
we're talking about fishing tackle which
I need a lot of and the highest quality
spare no expense that's different though
because if Society ever collapses and
we're back in the Stone Age and we need
to survive off of Fish and Wild forage
that lamp will do us no good the fishing
tackle Will Save Our Lives think about
it our friends at genell have launched a
new product called genell 3 which works
fast on your under eye bags and
puffiness gen cell 3 is smoother more
luxurious and it uses advanced
technology to deliver complex vitamins
and minerals directly to your face for
instant hydration it's like Gatorade for
your skin the new genu cell technology
keeps your skin looking young and
healthy for years to come genu cell fall
Classics package also includes a jawline
treatment for a more firm neck and
jawline it also includes genus cells
anti- wrinkle moisturizer and deep firm
serum get your skin ready for the cold
and dry weather if you don't look and
feel your absolute best you'll get your
money back no questions ask go to
genucell.com walshire you can call 800
skin 211 for extra discounts on this
amazing fall package get results in 12
hours or less the immediate effects are
included for free that's genucell.com
Walsh or by calling 800 skin
to11 anyway this isn't about me it's
about complaining about women so back to
girl math think about it this way here's
a helpful illustration
imagine if somebody burned down half of
our house imagine that we came home and
found that some guy was standing there
with matches and a can of gasoline and
half of our house was reduced to
smoldering Ash now imagine that we ran
up to that guy and we shouted you burned
down half of our house we're very upset
about this the dialogue isn't realistic
but that's not the point the point is
imagine if the guy responded by saying
no no no you see I was going to burn
down your whole house but instead it
only burned down half so really I just
gave you half a house you're welcome now
I think we would find that logic quite
unpersuasive given the circumstances and
that's basically girl math which also by
the way applies not just to money but to
time uh girl math for time it's a bit
more simple you know this one everyone
knows anytime a woman gives you a time
estimate for something multiply it by at
least two sometimes three it varies a
little bit by woman uh classic example
of course if she says it's going to take
her half an hour to get ready budget for
an hour if she tells you that it'll take
20 minutes to drive somewhere assume
that it'll be 45 minutes but this at
least is slightly more Justified because
time is relative so on planets where the
force of gravity is stronger time passes
more slowly do women experience gravity
more than men somehow could that explain
it further research is needed I don't
know but while your your wife's time
estimates may not be accurate on this
planet there are planets in the universe
where they would be accurate
theoretically the lamp on the other hand
the lamp is too expect ensive on every
planet and that is why girl math is
today cancelled if You' like to see what
else I have to say you can access my
full show by going to dailywire.com or
by going to the Matt wall Show Twitter
page hope to see you there Godspeed